hey everyone
did you know the native token of ripple
xrp has been in strong demand among
investors
the coin has increased by around 25 in
the last few days
with a 160 percent increase in its
volume putting it in sixth place among
crypto assets in terms of valuations
ahead of cardano and solano as well
yet there are many people who are still
unaware of this revolutionary
cryptocurrency and that's what i'm here
for
hey everyone i'm sharmly and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on what is ripple
in this video i will try to cover all
the important aspects related to ripple
so that all your questions related to it
could be answered
so let's get started but before moving
ahead please do hit the like button
and also click the bell icon to never
miss an update
through simplylearn
so let's have a look topics that we are
going to cover in this topic
first we will understand what is ripple
followed by what is xrp
then we will see the working of ripple
then we will learn how to mine xrp after
that we will have a comparison between
bitcoin and ripple then we will explore
the pros and cons of ripple
after which we will see how you can
actually use ripple
followed by we will see how can we buy
ripple
and in the end we will see if it is a
good investment or not
so let's get started with the video
first let's understand what is ripple so
the firm behind ex rp is ripple
which is a payment settlement systems
and currency engine network that can
handle transactions all across the world
basically it acts as a trusted
intermediary between two parties in a
transaction
as the network can be immediately
validated that the transaction was
completed successfully
ripple can ease the exchange of a wide
range
of fiat currencies and cryptocurrencies
including bitcoin
so when users utilize a network to make
a transaction the network takes a modest
charge in the form of xrp
and ripple was built from the ground up
to be a swift a leading money transfer
network successor or to otherwise
replace sentimental layer between large
financial institutions so this raises
the question of what is exile so let's
have a look at it the xrp ledger created
by jade mikhail arthur brito and david
schwartz is a blockchain that runs xrb
mckillib and brito would go on to form
ripple which would employ xrp to enable
network transactions
you can acquire xrp as an investment
crypto to trade from other
cryptocurrencies or as a way to fund
ripple network transactions
xrp is blockchain in particular drifted
from that of most other cryptocurrencies
other cryptocurrencies give anyone who
can solve difficult equations quickly
access to their transaction ledgers and
verification processes
ripple transactions on the other hand
are safe since the majority of ledger
holders must agree to the verification
before they can be added also the ripple
network which employs xrp
is somewhat centralized and uses a
consensus protocol this means
while anyone can download its validation
software it has its own node list that
consumers can use to validate
transactions based on which participants
they believe are least likely to cheat
them
so now that we know the basics of ripple
and xrp let's have a look at working of
ripple to verify transactions the xrp
cryptocurrency employs a consensus
protocol
validators verify that proposed
transactions are valid by comparing them
to the most recent version of the xrp
ledger
now what transaction must be accepted by
the majority of validators in order to
be verified once it's verified the
transaction is then added to the
blockchain so now that we know it's
working let's have a look at how ripple
can be mined by its users ripples or xr
is created using a crypto ledger that is
akin to blockchain technology and is
federated by financial institutions and
payment processor
networks while it is true that ripple
xrp cannot be mined by miners it is
technically viable to do it using other
cryptocurrencies so one of the most
viable techniques for mining xrp is to
mine other cryptocurrencies such as
bitcoin and ethereum and then transfer
the mine crypto for ripple through
exchanges
and that's how the mining is done
so as we have discussed all the basics
of ripple let's dive down deeper and
have a look at how it differs from
bitcoin
to verify transactions and distribute
new currencies bitcoin employs mining
participants set up mining devices to
solve complex mathematical equations
with the first person to solve the
equation winning the right to add a
block of transaction to bitcoin's
network
then participants receive bitcoin
rewards for each block they add in the
exchange for bitcoin mining
whereas the consensus protocol used by
xr plane confirms transactions for a
transaction to be accepted it must
receive the approval of a majority of
validators who actually review it then
bitcoin transaction confirms can take
several minutes and are associated with
significant transaction charges due to
the intricate
and expensive nature of mining utilized
in the cryptocurrency but on the other
hand xrp transactions are instantly
confirmed and have really cheap
transaction fees
the user is charged a small amount of
xrp each time a transaction is completed
on the ripple network
now the supply of bitcoin is limited to
21 million which means there will be
never more than 21 million bitcoin the
artificial scarcity of 12 bitcoin has
sparked investor interest in the
currency's potential as a safe haven but
in contrast at the time of introduction
one billion xrp was free mined and
progressively distributed onto the
market by the company's major investors
next we have when miners discover
bitcoins they are released and added to
the network they have no set release
date and their supplies is largely
determined by network speeds and the
difficulty of the algorithm used to
create coins
on the other hand the release of xrp is
controlled by a smart contract
according to an inbuilt smart contract
ripple is expected to distribute a
maximum of 1 billion xrp tokens per
month
so the current circulation is 55 billion
till now
so this was all about the difference
between bitcoin and ripple
and i'm pretty sure that till now you
have understood all the basic knowledge
about ripple so let's move ahead and
look into some of the pros and cons
of ripple
though xrp transactions are quick and
inexpensive ripple's consensus protocol
is perhaps less secure than other crypto
transaction processing technologies
next is
even though financial organizations are
already using ripple's payment network
ripple's financial partners primarily
use triple net rather than xrp
cryptocurrency
next we have is small company owners and
individuals who can utilize xrp to make
safe money transactions
yet because it is administered by a
private corporation and because of the
sec litigation ripple has sparked the
debate
and for foreign currency transfers xrp
can be utilized as a british currency
but in the united states buying serpi is
quite challenging so now that we know
its pros and cons also let's have a look
how you can actually use ripple
xrp can be used in same way as any
digital currency for transaction or as a
possible investment
other sorts of transactions such as
currency exchange potentially be
processed using the ripple network for
example instead of dealing with the
currency conversion directly through a
bank or money changing exchange you may
first exchange your us dollars for xrp
on the ripple network and then use them
to buy euros rather than paying the
hefty cost that banks and money
transmission businesses may demand this
can be a lot fast and less expensive
option
so now that we know everything about
ripple let's explore how can we actually
buy ripple
so all you need is sign up for an
account on an exchange that sells
ripples xrp cryptocurrency to buy it
then using any of the exchange's allowed
payment methods buy it here are a few
places where you can get xrp q coin
uphold and coin mama
now the question is
is ripple a good investment
so
xrp
is a risky investment that is not for
the faint of art
however if you feel ripple will succeed
as a payment system it may be worthwhile
to invest in xrp so just be sure you're
not gambling with money you can't afford
to lose
well this was all about what is ripple i
hope you enjoyed this video and learned
something new from it if you have any
questions related to the topics covered
in this video
feel free to ask out in the comment
section
our experts will reach out to you soon
thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here